depuis valéry giscard d'estaing prend le
relais propose de déposer un nouveau
texte pour annuler la loi votée à
l'assemblée nationale la motion de
censure sera discutée mais reçoit nice
jacques lafleur invité du 19/20 il été
reçu aujourd'hui à matignon par michel
rocard un an jour pour jour après la
tragique disparition de jean marie
tjibaou sommet franco-britannique
marquée par la déclaration de françois
mitterrand il se dit inquiet de la
fragilité de mikhaïl gorbatchev
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
laurent blanc
enfin refuge du progrès ou d'essence
d'une région centre est ce une partie de
la province préfère les cigales autres
élevé bonsoir pas de limite pour la
médecine des chercheurs américains ont
réussi à entrer si j'ose dire
dans la zone la plus mystérieuse la plus
inexplorées du corps humain le cerveau
et leur découverte permet d'espérer un
immense progrès et c'est une première
mondiale ces chercheurs de bâtiments ont
obtenu la croissance et la
multiplication de cellules du cerveau in
vitro
en clair les victimes de maladies de
traumatismes d'accident cérébral
pourront désormais retrouver toutes
leurs facultés
si ces études se confirme explications
jean jacques peyraud sept cellules
cultivées en éprouvette provient d'un
cerveau humain
jusqu'à aujourd'hui on ne pouvait pas la
maintenir en vie encore moins la faire
se reproduire si ce que vient de réussir
l'équipe du professeur sneijder de
baltimore depuis trois ans ils cultivent
in vitro des cellules prélevées sur le
cerveau d'une fillette de 18 mois
cette découverte qui a surpris tout le
monde et son auteur lui-même ouvre un
espoir immense mais lointain entendu
parler de transplantations de cellules
nerveuses des gens même parle de
transplantation de cerveau faut bien
préciser qu'il s'agit de
transplantations de cellules nerveuses
là on se dit si on est arrivé à faire
des cultures de cellules nerveuses
humaine on va peut-être pouvoir les
transplanter dans le cerveau de l'homme
et bien c'est quelque chose qui doit
rester à mon avis actuellement comme une
utopie
il faudra certainement pas se confirmer
ces résultats
voir ce qu'ils veulent dire ensuite
éventuellement éventuellement à long
terme passés à l'étape de
transplantation au cerveau mais d'abord
sur des petits animaux voire ceux
d'autres animaux avant de passer chez le
la crème de cerveau pas pour demain ni
après demain il reste que la découverte
de baltimore ouvre une voie de recherche
tout à fait nouvelle on va pouvoir
expérimenter des médicaments sur des
cellules nerveuses en culture
aucun neurologue monde ne l'imaginait
hier encore et de deux après la lituanie
la lettonie proclame son indépendance
le vote a eu lieu en fin d'après-midi
138 voix contre 58 la république
socialiste soviétique de lettonie
devient donc la république de lettonie
mais attention cette indépendance n'est
pas immédiate elle s'accompagne d'une
période transitoire de rigueur la
correspondance de notre envoyé spécial
hélène risacher la lettonie est donc la
troisième république balte a officialisé
sa volonté d'indépendance
après de longs débats où les anti
indépendantistes on utilisait toutes les
procédures d'obstruction parlementaire
mais les députés indépendantistes du
front populaire majoritaire ont eu
largement gain de cause
la déclaration d'indépendance et voter
pendant ce temps dans la rue la
population consomme ces désaccords
groupe folklorique de riga et chant
patriotique lé ton contre les cris des
anti-indépendantistes non au fascisme
nous voulons un référendum entre les
deux blocs les miliciens mais le face à
face reste verbale et les anti
indépendantistes sont moins nombreux
vous voyez leur slogan dit cette femme
urss ss et tout ça moi je suis russe
mais je vis ici depuis très longtemps et
maintenant j'ai peur j'ai peur de la
discrimination et de la haine de ces
gens contre nous nous nous voulons vivre
en paix vous savez moi je suis russe
mais je suis né à riga c'est ma terre
alors qu'est ce que je vais devenir si
la lettonie devient indépendante avec
ces gens qui nous détestent et qui nous
considère comme des occupants
moi je suis letton est la seule solution
pour notre pays c'est l'indépendance
être libre pour l'instant on se sent
occupée si moscou fait un blocus
économique comme en lituanie et bien
nous on travaillera plus et on s'en
sortira moi j'avais 18 ans quand staline
est arrivé j'ai vu les morts à la
frontière à cause des soviétiques il
faut retrouver notre liberté notre terre
et la discrimination c'est un faux
problème
le texte de la déclaration
d'indépendance condamne l'annexion de la
lettonie en 1940 par staline déclare la
république
layton démocratique et indépendante est
rétabli defacto la souveraineté perdue
il ya 50 ans la transition vers
l'indépendance aux crêtes pourrait durer
de deux à quatre ans sous le contrôle du
parlement de lettonie dans leur texte de
déclaration d'indépendance
les lettons sont plus modérées que les
lituaniens afin d' éviter de braquer les
autorités de moscou
mais sur le fond la détermination des
indépendantistes semble très forte
reste à savoir maintenant comment
concrètement ils vont organiser leur
sortie de l'union soviétique la
situation union soviétique préoccupe les
dirigeants occidentaux george bush
craint qu'un coup d'état ne renversent
michael gorbatchev craintes partagées et
exprimé par françois mitterrand à
londres lors de sa rencontre aujourd'hui
avec margaret thatcher le reportage de
notre envoyé spécial mémona hintermann
prend on se fait quelquefois des
gentillesses est aujourd'hui margaret
thatcher a voulu faire plaisir à
françois mitterrand on l'a vite heures
la campagne dans un endroit où aucun
autre chef d'état étranger l'été venu à
titre officiel le manoir de wade donne
c'est une construction de style
renaissance réalisé par un français pour
le baron de rothschild au siècle dernier
les entretiens aujourd'hui on est
concentré d'abord sur la réforme de
l'alliance atlantique
dans cette perspective la france et la
grande bretagne vont accroître la
coopération en matière d'armement et la
matière de sécurité en solitaire on
s'est félicité du fait que l'otan
s'appuie aujourd'hui sur les mêmes idées
qu'il avait préconisé dès le sommet de
mars 1988
en réalité on s'est rendu compte ici que
ni bagarres nature ni françois
mitterrand n'avait les moyens de peser
dans l'immédiat sur les modifications
profondes et immédiate de l'alliance
atlantique
tout se décide à washington et peut-être
également que tout se décide en union
soviétique
l'union soviétique c'était le deuxième
thème essentiel des discussions le
président de la république et le premier
ministre britannique
apparu relativement inquiets des
difficultés du président bâtisseur on
décèle ici el had des fragilités qui
peuvent être dangereuses mais nous avons
nous dans l'esprit qu'il convient de
contribuer autant que cela nous est
possible à ce que le chu gorbatchev
puisse poursuivre son oeuvre de
rénovation de réforme et de
modernisation
donc ne parions pas sûr seul échec
madame thatcher qui a subi un sérieux
revers électoral hier c'est une position
des défis vous gré at elle dit en 1993
nous allons inaugurer ensemble et là
regardez français durant le tunnel sous
la gorge pour soi mitterrandiste et que
l'opinion peut varier a répondu oui oui
1993 et dans le moyen françois
mitterrand aura l'occasion d'évoquer
avec michael gorbatchev les difficultés
que le numéro un soviétique et prouve en
ce moment les deux hommes se
rencontreront à moscou le 25 mai les
hommes politiques français vont sans
doute mettre à profit la trêve du 8 mai
pour se reposer la semaine prochaine
promet en effet d'être orageuses avec la
discussion au parlement à propos de la
motion de censure déposée par
l'opposition et du côté de l'opposition
justement valéry giscard d'estaing a
pris le relais ce matin en proposant de
déposer un nouveau texte pour annuler la
loi d'aministie malgré sur nous-mêmes ce
débat de fond politique l'assemblée
nationale et est aujourd'hui presque
déserte reportage philippe de ses skis
henry deutsch aide aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale les passes d'armes
n'avait rien de parlementaires les
députés avaient déjà déserté l'hémicycle
quelques vétérans assuré le vote de
leurs collègues
la motion de censure contre la loi
d'aministie ne sera discutée qu'après le
pont du 8 mai néanmoins la polémique
occupent toujours les esprits
mettons les choses à plat et refaisons
des lois digne de la république
je pense qu'il doit y avoir une
séparation totale entre la justice et le
politi côté communiste on s'étonne que
la droite réagit si violemment
car si l'udf le rpr et les centristes
étaient tous prononcés contre la loi
aurait été repoussée aussi les députés
communistes sont-ils perplexe concernant
la motion de censure ou la proposition
giscard
ce qui est pour eux ça changera eu lieu
ont t ils lui ont été les communistes
mettent aussi en doute la sincérité de
la droite quand celle ci dit qu'elle a
été trompée par le gouvernement mais
bernard pons persiste et signe
gouvernement a affirmé que les
politiques étaient exclus du bénéfice de
la loi puis on voit le résultat
donc nous avons la preuve que le
gouvernement a trompé le parlement qui
en profite selon vous à l'heure actuelle
ceux qui en profitent tout le savait
très bien ce sont ceux qui parlent les
positions les plus extrêmes et les plus
dangereux aussi la droite prend tel un
risque car si sa motion est votée il
aura dissolution et en cas de
législatives elle sera confrontée un
front national très offensif mais pour
que la motion de censure aboutisse il
faut que les communistes se joignent à
la droite ce qui semble improbable même
si le pc laisse planer le suspense sur
cette position
revenons sur la proposition de valérie
giscard d'estaing est elle réellement
compatible avec la constitution
française
nous avons posé cette question
essentielle un spécialiste du droit
constitutionnel
patrick duhamel en lait coûte tout de
suite olivier dion olivier je ne pense
pas qu'une telle loi soit possible ou en
tout cas je ne pense pas qu'une telle
loi soit constitutionnel
je veux dire une loi qui annule les
amnisties déjà opéré une fois cani
astier lieu elle a eu lieu et si on
prenait une nouvelle loi comme giscard
d'estaing j'imagine j'ose imaginer que
le conseil constitutionnel serait saisie
parce qu'il s'agit d'un vrai problème de
droit et là il serait obligé de
considérer qu'il ya le principe de non
rétroactivité qui empêche que des gens
ayant bénéficié d' amnistie n'en
bénéficient plus vous avez des lois
pénales rétroactive notamment dans le
pire moment de notre histoire qui était
pendant le régime de vichy ou dans la
sphère des sections spéciales on a créé
des lois rétroactives pour pour vertu
desquelles ce sont des gens se sont même
retrouvés condamnés à mort et exécutés
et c'est pour ça que maintenant encore
plus depuis cette affaire'' épouvantable
on assimile dans notre pays mais c'était
écrit déjà dans la déclaration de 1789
l'état de droit à la non rétroactivité
de la loi pénale
jacques lafleur bonsoir bonsoir mais
vous avez d'autres soucis en ce moment à
propos de la nouvelle calédonie quand
vous êtes ici à paris comment réagissez
vous à ce débat sur la mise
j'ai débuté quand même je ne suis et
j'aime et des opinions aux votants et je
vais voter comme opposition comme la
position de l'opposition n'a rien à se
reprocher qui n'ont rien à se reprocher
comme le disent c'est déjà plus
compliqué alors on vous a invité parce
que vous avez été reçu aujourd'hui par
michel rocard est ce une coïncidence
mais vous avez été reçu un an jour pour
jour après l'assassinât de jean marie
thibeault willy william ans après
comment le fln caisse at il survécu à ce
drame et quels ont été les incidences de
la mort de jean marie tjibaou sur le
comportement des indépendantistes
réponse tout de suite
avec anne rongère s'il fallait conserver
une image de diva ou ce pourrait être
celle-là inhabituel le chef des
indépendantistes dansante un pilou
endiablé grave et rieurs à la fois
lorsqu'il est assassiné le jour
anniversaire de la tragédie d'ouvéa
c'est plus qu'un symbole qui s'écroule
sous les balles de cet homme c'est
presque un mythe car tjibaou était plus
qu'un chef politique
c'était le père d'une famille nombreuse
et turbulente le fln qui au fil des
années cet ancien prêtre avait réussi à
structurer la mosaïque indépendantiste
puis l'avait convaincu de quitter les
chemins de la violence
un an après le fln qui se sont toujours
orphelin mais l'héritage de djibo est là
comme ces pêcheurs qui ont monté une
coopérative
les indépendantistes se sont lancés dans
la bataille économique
les messages de tjibaou est passé à nier
la bataille économie fait partie de la
vampirisation politique
je dirais aussi que le les résultats
économiques consolider l avant des
questions pour l'été en tout cas avant
le crédit qui va ou disparus à paradoxe
c'est leur ennemi d'hier qui aident
aujourd'hui les indépendantistes dans ce
pari c'est un prix d'ami que jacques
lafleur vient de céder ses mines de
nickel au fln cas est ce un geste
symbole le partage d'une richesse
longtemps aux seules mains des grandes
familles
il ya un an
on craignait le retour de la violence
même si tjibaou n'est plus là la paix
semble survivre
la question va peut-être vous surprendre
jacques lafleur et vous même comment
vivez-vous sans jean marie tjibaou
puis je vous dire que je n'ai pas vendu
au final 15 parce que je considère que
je répondrai à deux questions en même
temps jean marie thibeault était le chef
de l'union que les aliens et
accessoirement le chef du journal 15 une
structure et permis de mener un
mouvement insurrectionnel à certains
moments et de retour à la paix il était
le président de l'union plaide donc de
rectification importante
c'est à la province nord majorité
mélanésiens que j'ai vendu la société
minière à un prix d'ami ont pris
sûrement sûrement en tout cas pour
qu'ils aient progrès que nous reste il
ya progrès politique on peut le noter
même sens jean marie si je vivais
saint-thibault bien sûr ces objets
d'hier senti l'eau je crois que c'est
une personnalité qui a marqué il a pris
le risque de s'engager et de voeux
grossistes processus de paix et ont
chacun sait ce que ça lui a coûté il
fallait du courage
le sapin on parle moins de la nouvelle
calédonie et c'est tant mieux dans une
certaine mesure parce que le calme règne
là-bas est ce que ce sera un calme
définitif le représentant du foulques
premier des troubles dit il je crois
qu'il ya toujours des extrémistes tels
que soit le bord où se tourne
je crois que c'est définitif je crois
que la conversation que j'ai eue ce
matin avec le premier ministre notamment
en parlant de l'avenir de l'assertion
économique des mélanésiens
c'est une façon d'assurer sa poupée qui
règne dans les coeurs lorsqu'aujourd'hui
le véritable nom est né l'espérance ont
bousculé et c'est curieux parce que vous
apparaissez ici à paris comme un homme
seul dans votre camp vous allez voter
avec l'opposition d'un produit prochain
sur l'amnistié mais à propos de nouvelle
calédonie vous apparaissez comme un
petit peu seul non je ne crois pas cela
je pense que j'ai à certains moment
était mal compris dans l'action que je
me dis parce que me demander pourquoi
maintenant et pourquoi pas avant je
pense que les
conditions ont été réunies après j'ai eu
des drames qui n'est pas le seul mort de
ces événements et je regrette sa mort
aujourd'hui et je regrette celle de tous
ceux qui sont donc vous êtes optimiste
pour l'avenir je suis je peux le dire
très optimiste
merci jacques lafleur après les
dernières mutinerie la sécurité dans les
prisons est une nouvelle fois à la une
avec la publication aujourd'hui du
rapport karsenti le dossier confidentiel
du monsieur prison du gouvernement a été
rompue rendu public ce matin mais
attention la transparence de la
chancellerie a des limites seule une
synthèse très édulcoré a été présenté
reportage morad aït habbouche et sage
florimont si bonne semaine sur le
terrain 33 prison visitée
résultat un rapport de 80 pages sur la
sécurité dans les établissements
carcéraux
mais six pages seulement de synthèse
révélé à la presse
revue et édulcorée d'ailleurs par la
chancellerie une bonne raison à cela
nous at on dit on ne peut pas mettre sur
la place publique les défaillances et
les pois noirs qui existe ce serait trop
lourd de conséquences reste que les
constats sont là on sait par exemple que
il faut renforcer les murs d'enceinte on
sait qu'il faut renforcer les grillages
qui sont la séparation des terrains
sport on sait qu'il faut éviter et c'est
oui les gens pour éviter qu'ils arrivent
en cours de promenade avec des cisailles
sur eux ou des grappins bref on sait
beaucoup de choses
cela dit pour mettre en oeuvre ces
choses il faut d'abord des moyens parce
que tout ceci coûte de l'argent
ensuite il faut d'humour plus d'agents
de surveillance et plus d'équipements un
état des lieux et des besoins sans
complaisance mais lorsqu'il s'agit de
parler chiffres
je ferai c'est madame de noir répondre
répondre la question noëlle lenoir la
directrice de cabinet de pierre
arpaillange un peu gêné nous n'aurons
qu'un élément sur les moyens à mettre en
oeuvre pour assurer la sécurité
et il semble bien que les estimations
des besoins du rapport karsenti soient
jugés trop irréaliste par la
chancellerie
seul chiffre qui figure dans la synthèse
celui des évasions les prisons
françaises ne sont pas des passoires
le taux d'évasion est l'un des plus
faibles d'europe la provence préfère la
pelle les cigales et les olives
au progrès on peut sérieusement se poser
la question depuis des mois en effet les
opposants au tracé du tgv ne désarment
pas leur slogan sézanne réveille toi ils
sont devenus fous
la sncf joue pourtant la concertation
mais la provence restent sur le pied de
guerre portage sur place de véronique
aurel et christian de carnets pas besoin
de vous faire un dessin supplémentaires
une ligne de tgv ne serait pas joli joli
dans ce tableau de 6 haine ni dans le
paysage qui l'a inspiré voilà pourquoi
dans tout le pays d'aix
on ne peut pas le voir en peinture ce
train à grande vitesse on ne peut pas
notre époque où l'environnement est un
sujet brûlant venir être si
irrespectueux de type qui nous reste en
provence il ya aussi la magnétique
placée sur un coteau l'autoroute 10
beaucoup parlent d'eux mêmes de leur
procès encore une fois on cooper ont
découpé il avait pas question la
paisible commune de landesk a été la
première à brandir le drapeau de la
révolte aujourd'hui 33 communes se sont
jointes à elles les dizaines
d'associations ont vu le jour
s'y retrouvent des viticulteurs des élus
des châteliers de simples riverains
pas une seule fausse note dans ce
concert de protestations les ministres
ont décidé à l'erreur et tracer des
traits voilà on va passer là bas on fait
péter qu'un coupé en abyme au serbe mais
ça fait en france gamerre vous pouvez
admettre non 1106 neuilly pas le refaire
le coup de la diligence ils comprennent
autant que d'autres la nécessité du
progrès simplement pour aller vite il
est humain qui le souhaitent plus humain
que technique
nos objectifs technocratique de sncf qui
effectivement de gagner dix minutes
entre avignon et marseille nous paraît
de totalement disproportionnée par
rapport aux dommages subis à notre
région je peux pas dire que je compte
peut être avais je suis par contre
l'électricité mais je trouve que pas
comme on dit pas n'importe quel prix pas
n'importe quel tgv pas n'importe qui il
n'y a pas que le tgv il n'y a pas que la
rapidité des transports dans la vie il
ya d'autres valeurs comme on dit ce tgv
à mon avis
il va servir à des parisiens c'est tout
des parisiens qui vont faire du bateau à
cannes
moi je veux bien peut-être y en aura
beaucoup il se rapportera beaucoup
d'argent à la sncf mais il n'ya pas que
les parisiens qu'est ce que vous voulez
madame face à ces critiques la sncf
cherche depuis quelques semaines un
compromis le tracé de référence n'est
plus qu'une première hypothèse la
contestation oblige la sncf à concilier
la vitesse avec moins de précipitation
hold up est prise d'otages à bastia
c'est l'un des événements du jour
couvert par toutes nos stations
régionales est résumé par terre
sébastien l2 les prises d'otages en
corse ce matin deux malfaiteurs ont
quitté options rares montois dans
l'agencé parle de matthias huss 1 150
migrants bilan un blessé grave
l'employé pris en otage pour ouvrir la
[ __ ] et m'a créateur est assommé avant
d'être libéré daniel plessier tilman
pour quelques lattes de voix le 2
septembre en quatre vingt huit accusés
de ce larcin cet agriculteur et gardé à
vue une nuit durant la gendarmerie on le
retrouvera mans dans sa cellule le
lendemain matin le gendarme de garde
cette nuit là a été inculpé d'homicide
involontaire et non-assistance à
personne en danger
à partir de ce soir je ne mange plus
tard que je n'ai pas un contrat d'un an
et à 1 à 2 à nîmes les torts et on voit
rouge motif trop d'espagnol et pas assez
de français à la fiche détresse corrida
de la prochaine feria ce soir le
directeur des arènes de nîmes simon
casas a cédé 6 français au lieu des deux
prévues seront dans l'arène on redoute à
présent la grève des taureaux l'incendié
qui a entièrement détruit la nuit
dernière l'entrepôt de peinture de
l'entreprise herbert tally mais serait
très certainement d'origine criminelle
c'est en tout cas ce qu'affirme le pdg
de la société elise lucet passionné par
le rugby alors je ne surtout pas la
priver du plaisir de vous en parler
j'adore ça je vous parle des gardes
finale des championnats de france qui se
dispute ce week-end à match phare dès
demain le stade toulousain contre
narbonne toulouse avec des stars du
rugby comme charvet eaubonne val mais
entourée de petits nouveaux qui ont
beaucoup de talent reportage andré marc
1985 un stade toujours un nul ou grâce à
une politique de jeunes toulon faisait
les frais de ce renouveau en perdant la
finale au parc des princes
cinq ans après de nouveaux jeunes
frappent à la porte et les lendemains du
stade toulousain sont assurés guy novès
hier slalomeur aujourd'hui entraîneur
misé sur cet atout je n'ai fait que
aussi rendu compte qu'il n'est pas du
tout difficile des cas déjà devant si
sur des jeunes de qualité lieux réels
des kids à défiler nous avons intégré en
équipe et je crois qu'il a montré dès le
début c'est un garçon d'avenir de talent
puisqu'il a déjà fait la finale l'année
dernière et donc de déjà champion de
france je crois que ça soit comme david
berty et en version vraiment avec un
titre en plastique en version comme
stéphane rougier d'un garçon aussi les
détails techniques fantastique
s'ils gardent aussi la tête sur les
épaules je crois que l'on peut penser
que ça peut faire
il est vrai que l'exemple vient toujours
des maîtres à jouer et avec erik
bonneval et denis charvet
le tattoo
n'a pas de tous à se taire ou son avenir
la classe dans quelques minutes votre
magazine de la mer thalassa de pernod à
20h35 et une nouvelle fiction suivre
l'a3 et tisserands du pouvoir voilà le
programme de l'a350 et vous avec
l'information c'est à 22h centre soir 3
présenté par marc hautement tout de
suite la météo complète de florence
klein fin de ce 19 20 à lundi 19h pour
une nouvelle édition demain 12h45
eric à charbon soir bonsoir à lundi
de nous